shinobi have you ever heard someone
playing the shamisen around here I
followed the sound and it led me to this
well it's faint carried by the wind it's
coming from this hole you hear it do you
not I hear nothing I see
perhaps I alone can hear it nothing else
matters I must follow that melody
it truly stirs my soul this sound winds
upwards from an ancient decrepit village
it's a village hidden by the mists mists
that coil in a forest a forest deep
below the earth only the devoted or the
exiled can find it now will you be cast
out or throw yourself what if you wish
to go to the very depths of Ashima then
you'd best cast yourself out it's hard
to know what the lives of the ancient
hashanah were like save that they lived
on land that was coveted by many the
gate before this jump is a torii gate
which marks the transition from the
mundane to the sacred and the land below
is indeed sacred so sacred in fact that
the water rocks and soil here in mibu
village once attracted the attention of
the gods one of the gods worships here
was likely the serpent God as its skin
is found throughout the village and
another was likely Buddha deity friendly
with the serpent God whose statue can be
found desecrated in the main temple then
far away to the west some event caused
the Sakura dragon to be cut free from
its homeland it drifted to the east to
Japan where it found the fertile depths
of Hashanah then it settled here
conjuring a divine realm usurping the
lesser gods and tearing the fate of mibu
village in half it seems like a lucky
few would have immediately become
citizens of the
these Nobles but that also means that
most of mibu had to simply content
themselves with the divine waters that
begin flowing through their village
these waters bestowed a ton of bounties
upon the meadow bounties that were
distributed throughout all of a Sheena
dragon Springs sake a drink that no
words can do justice me boo balloons
orbs of water that was sealed with
bountiful prayers and even magnificent
medicines good enough to be stored in
this chest apparently created by Dogon
the famous doctor and yet for all the
perks that were offered by its proximity
the divine realm still a tragically out
of reach until the Okami clan arrived in
mibu village this group of warrior women
technically called the carajo kami clan
were among the first to figure out how
to ascend they did this by accruing
three ingredients that they knew were
stemming from The Fountainhead
and they created incense with them the
first ingredient was the stem of a
sakura tree for even to this day a
Sakura blooms in mibu village it might
even be an ever blossom and the mibu
have prayed with the power of Sakura for
the longest time the second ingredient
was the fragrance of a flower that
thrives in the deepest waters of The
Fountainhead
they called it a Lotus of the palace and
lastly they offered a shelter stone
which is something that grows inside the
body of one who has long drank from the
fountain headwaters it's a lot like
these cancer like grave wax lumps that
manifest in all of the undead in the
game
and these shelters stone rocks too can
appear in the bodies of those who drink
from these immortal waters and wrapped
in The Fountainhead fragrance the Okami
ascended to the palace here like the
palace Nobles before them they too could
drink of the purest waters beginning
this transformation into life carp like
beings and as this journey to the
Fountainhead entered the realm of
possibility a culture of dragons spring
pilgrimage began to emerge what year is
it
what here and hard question tell me it's
the year of the dragon spring pilgrimage
every few years those seeking to join
the wedding procession would journey to
me boo drawn to the village by black
pine trees which was set aflame with a
fire that never went out if you could
pass a test then you were able to join a
procession that led all the way to the
wedding chamber a place that we know
gives you the chance at admission to the
divine palace and the founder of mibu
village states that the goal of this
procession was to meet the divine dragon
and for this participants were required
to master the secret
me brew breathing technique which allows
one to breathe underwater without this
the dragon cannot be met and my best
guess is that breathing underwater
somehow facilitates a transformation
into becoming a noble of the palace
you're basically becoming a fish after
all and perhaps this is why we find so
many upturned legs underneath me boo
Lake failed practice at breathing
underwater perhaps or perhaps they
burrowed underground looking for slugs
amia because all over the village we
find a sort of slug harvest they're on
boards they're piled up on the ground
where the mibu are digging
they're everywhere and
might even be valuable if they're the
same type as those found in the precious
bait tooltip' because this is food that
was given to the master carp that was
found at Fountainhead palace this would
be a good example of an item that the
mibu could have brought to the palace
for trade because there was trade
between the divine realm and the
Hashanah our proof is in the Dragons
tally board a sort of Idol that was
given to merchants who were recognized
as of dragon rank by the Imperial Palace
all was going well but then war the
Okami suddenly and without cause it
seems descended upon a sheena they did
battle with its people and they put an
end to any goodwill that did exist
between the two lands all records of
this war call it long-forgotten so we
have no idea what triggered this
animosity perhaps the nobles began to
age and began craving the vitality of
the Ashna maybe the dragon began to get
sick or I wonder if the okami simply
became ambitious whatever it was we know
that it was almost certainly initiated
by The Fountainhead because it came at
little cost to them because even though
their assault was eventually repelled by
the poison of sabi Maru
it's unlikely that the okami ever
descended in their physical forms the
hanging scroll of an old battle hung in
a sheena dojo speaks of lightning
wielding ghosts that once lurked in the
lands of the hashanah and this is the
description that can fit the Okami
these women wield lightning which is a
power of the divine dragon and there are
three known instances of the okami
projecting apparitions down upon the
physical realm the first is that of Orin
of the water if you're wondering why we
count her as of the okami well it's
because her ghostly form is actually
weak to the poison of sabi Maru which is
effective against the Okami this is
important information to know
you're not getting past this shamisen
player without a fight
why are you crying because I'm sad what
are you sad about I don't know where
Lord
Sakura is or what he's doing it breaks
my heart if I can't see him I'd at least
like to know but no matter how many
letters I said he never writes me back
and no one will tell me where he is
actually sir can you tell me where is
lord Sakura's ah I don't know you are a
liar too
why must everyone I do from me you're
probably sitting there waiting for me to
explain Aaron's law but honestly it's
tough there are no other references to
Lord saccuzzo in the game save for one
this item description of Jin's as Jizo
statue which Jin's Amon gives to you at
the end of his journey I must give you
my thanks Toby
no thanks you brought the shamisen
player to me just a moment ago she
caressed me playing her sweet melody it
turns out she was calling to me this
whole time
shinobi please take this I'm
so very tired now this statue was once
given to Lord saccuzzo and assumedly
this was by errand of the water somehow
it ended up in Jin's a man's hands and
my best guess is that loadsa Cuza gave
this statue to jinns a man's father
because jinns a man's father does know
about me boo village
he probably eventually passed this down
to jinns Amon with a warning never visit
the ominous town hidden in the mists the
second apparition of the okami is the
corrupted monk of course whose nebulous
formed guards the mibu village cave
entrance after the war it's unlikely
that anymore marriage processions were
being accepted at the palace and this
animosity becomes the simplest
explanation from a threatening presence
here the third set of apparitions of the
bandits conjured by the mist Noble in
the hidden forest this boss has usurped
one of Buddhist temples adorning it with
a more homely feel and he strings the
poor monks up by their ankles you will
you slay he who poses Buddha the one of
whom I speak hides in an abandoned
temple up ahead he sealed away the
village in a shadowy fog so that he can
fool the villagers I've gotten terribly
over but this old man would like to see
Lord Buddha return to his temple once
more the most curious reveal of this
dialogue is that the Mist Noble seeks to
seal the village away to fool the
villagers I'm pretty sure I know what
fooling the villagers means because by
sealing away the village you're
essentially maintaining this status quo
in mibu village preventing the buddhist
monks from returning to the village and
keeping the village isolated from the
world
but the manipulation of the villages
goes even further Basque basket basket
basket I am a basket this basket case is
named Osaka one of the few who actually
resisted the temptation of drinking the
now stagnant water of The Fountainhead
what is wrong with this village I sure
like to know that too before I knew it
everyone had gone insane for a while
I too was in a daze but nice snapped out
of it after I threw up I was thirsty so
I drink a lot of sake
I'm sure that's what made me throw up
the head priest sometimes treats us to
sake but you know when you drink sake
you get thirsty the sukkah cask runs dry
in no time so everyone has no choice but
to drink the water in the ponds and
rivers but the more you drink it the
thirstier you get you get thirstier and
thirstier get ever drink enough the
water here was obviously once very pure
but now it's stagnant and something's
wrong with it
it is of course very similar to the
rejuvenating waters of a sauna as the
villagers who drink this become undying
because when you kill one villager the
very same villager resurrects a few
moments later confirming that the
villages are in fact undying and on top
of that they now have this undying fear
of fire which is also in line with our
Sheena's rejuvenating water
unquenchable fire even now the thought
of it gives me chills the hunter in
Oheka started burning pine resin and
locked himself in his house his pine
resin burns a long time it's a real
nuisance the villages previously
destroyed these black pines that were
guiding people to the village but now it
seems like a man named Eno HECO defended
those pines and hoarded their ever
burning resin for this the water
drinking villagers came to loathe him
and they hide in the earth outside his
home just waiting for him to come out
you know he Co is the village outcasts
he likes eating wild animal meat in his
sword that's why the head priest doesn't
give him any sake the head priest is
holed up inside the main temple and he's
hoarding what is almost certainly sake
from the dragon spring yes I can feel it
dissolving liquefy oh the cop has run
dry but this won't do
it's too dilute refuses to dissolve
completely unfit to be citizens of the
palace in the fountainhead palace you
can find this pure water of the palace
which was a drink that once visitors to
the palace were greeted with when they
arrived it transforms the priest into a
noble confirming three things first that
humans can become nobles second that
those with red robes are high-ranking
head priests and third the fact that he
drops carp scales confirms that the
nobles of the palace are in fact carp
like inform explaining me booze affinity
for slugs and also explaining the
worship of the great cop
as I tie this episode up some of you
might be saying hey buddy why don't you
talk about the giant rope creature at
the end of mibu village but technically
it also appears in The Fountainhead as
well so until then afraid not if you can
forgive that pun then consider checking
out the new merge below the video this
is the fate of Kings the skull of a
monarch offered up in a dark ritual the
goal with my merch is to kind of give
off the same vibe as many of the souls
games give because I think it's cool to
rep the games that you're passionate
about without wearing clothing that's to
video game II and I think we walked that
line pretty well here the art is
available in red bronze or a black and
white line art and sales from this also
directly support the artist John Devlin
as well who recently had some of his art
put on merchandise and sold without his
permission
so it's a pleasure to be able to give
the guy some legitimate sales in return
and it's really fun to create
merchandise that you might feel proud of
wearing so please if you're running low
on t-shirts or maybe you need a hoodie
to keep you warm in the winter then
consider the fate of Kings and I'll see
you in the next one